greetings my fellow Communists this is
the commune we're communists
episode 6 of The Last of Us although a
slower episode deviates quite a bit from
the game and introduces us to Jackson
Wyoming and potentially one of The Last
of Us Part two's major characters so
we'll be taking a deep dive into the
episode Easter eggs from the game and at
the end redistributing all your wealth
now be a good comrade and smash that
like And subscribe button seriously only
20 of you are subscribed because here we
go the episode begins with the final
chilling moments of episode 5 the death
of Sam by his own brother the irony not
forgotten that Henry did everything to
save his brother from leukemia yet he's
the one who ends up killing him the game
fast forwards to fall while in the show
it's three months later we're now in
Wyoming the place Joel's brother Tommy
was last heard from if they find Tommy
he may know where this secret Firefly
base is the one filled with doctors who
might be able to synthesize a cure for
the cordyceps virus using Ellie's immune
blood at first glance we see a man
holding a bow with some Dead Rabbits and
not to the beginning of the winter
segment from the game there's even a
deer strung up the animal Ellie chases
which eventually leads her to David we
haven't met him in the show but if you
played the game you'll know he has some
interesting tastes this time it's not
Ellie or Joel with the bow but a man
named Marlon a resident here in the vast
Wilderness of Wyoming jolinelli have
held Marlin's partner Florence at
gunpoint looking to find just where they
are on this map Florence was even nice
enough to make him some soup he made him
soup for those with a Keen Eye you'll
pick up the color of Florence's sweater
purple or as Maria will later refer to
it as eggplant it's been worn by several
characters throughout this series from a
Tess Sarah and even Ellie its color can
symbolize a wide array of things from
trustworthiness to wisdom to immaturity
now Joel here has already asked Florence
where they are on this map and now asks
Marlon the same question to see if
they're lying Marlin and Florence
characters who are not in the game come
across as this old bickering married
couple in fact it was Marlin who dragged
Florence out here even though she wasn't
a fan of the seclusion the irony here
that this seclusion is probably what
saved their lives once the pandemic hit
in fact these two seem so far off the
grid they haven't even heard of the
fireflies there are Firefly people they
do know however that cities like Cody
Laramie and the Wind River Reservation
have all been taken over by infected and
the bodies they've seen along the river
scared them from going any further west
if we're going by the map Marlin points
out here the supposed death River as
they call it is actually the Yellowstone
River found in Yellowstone National Park
so we can see here there are quite a
ways away from their next destination
the city of Jackson on their Journey
West toward death River Ellie snatches
one of the rabbits their hunger is
something we'll see on full display once
they eventually reach Jackson and
something that's also mentioned in the
game you hungry
starving the show introduces Joel to his
first series of panic attacks something
he doesn't experience in the game he'll
later describe the sensation to Tommy as
a feeling of fear so numbing that his
heart stops these panic attacks are tied
to his inability to save and protect
Ellie which in itself is rooted in his
trauma of losing his daughter he has one
on their way to death River one when the
guard dog approaches zelly and another
when he finds a girl who looks like his
daughter one of the things I loved about
this episode was this cinematography we
get these absolutely gorgeous shots of
the Wilderness as Joel and Ellie make
their way west much of the first half of
the episode is framed to juxtapose
Joel's change in character near the
latter half for example Joe doesn't want
to teach Ellie how to hunt but later
when he chooses to stick with her he
becomes his father-like figure and
teaches her how to shoot and what father
wouldn't want to share some of his
precious Hooch
so gross the journey is not an easy one
Joel and Ellie have been traveling by
foot for three whole months we'll see
Joel using duct tape on his boots and
one of the game's most resourceful items
Ellie looks up to the stars at an aurora
borealis to the fox natives the Aurora
symbolizes the dancing of restless
Spirits with the term aurora borealis
translating from Greek to Sunrise wind
it's here we learn of Ellie's
fascination with space in particular the
astronaut Sally Ride who was the first
American to travel there in her room in
Jackson in The Last of Us Part Two she
even has an astronaut figurine and a
poster of her favorite sci-fi comic
Savage Starlight the same one we saw Sam
pick up last episode in The Last of Us
Part 2 Joel takes Ellie to the Wyoming
Museum of Science and History where
there's a large exhibit called a walk
through the Stars it's his surprise 16th
birthday present to her and even
culminates in a reenactment of a launch
Ellie is curious what they're going to
do after they reach the fireflies and
Joel's like excuse me we if there's one
episode where Joel is a complete [__]
it's this one it's all part of his
defense mechanism to protect him from
the pain he felt from losing those
closest to him he tells her he'd one day
like to own a ranch and raise a bunch of
sheep ironic because Joel is literally
shepherding Ellie across the country
just like he protected Tommy before her
but Ellie is reluctant that a vaccine
will even work it's been three months
and only now does she tell him about
what happened to Sam remember she tried
to rub her own blood onto Sam's wound in
the hopes it would cure him but it
didn't all Joel can say is that he
trusts Marlene if she says it can be
done it can be done jolt tells Ellie
he'll take both watches tonight but just
like Ellie fell asleep promising to stay
by Sam so too does Joel doze off with
the mumbling in his sleep he's having
one of his night terrors something we
saw him experience in episode one later
he'll tell Tommy that he has these
nightmares every night but can never
remember them only this tremendous
feeling of fear however we heard the
sounds of Sarah dying in his nightmare
in episode one so what's likely he's
replaying that moment over and over
again as they make their way across
death River they come across a
hydroelectric Dam and Ellie can't help
but unleash her inner will Livingston
the author of her book of puns damn this
is where the show deviates from the game
in the game Joel reunites with his
brother and wife Maria here at the dam
this plant Powers electricity to the
nearby city of Jackson which we only see
briefly from the outside in The Last of
Us Part 1 but plays a more prominent
role in part two Joel doesn't even try
to explain how these dams work a
throwback to how he failed miserably
explaining the physics behind siphoning
this and not to how he's so bad at
explaining things in the game look I
know what it is I don't know how it does
it while the game explores the
hydroelectric Dam the show Ventures to
Jackson itself something a lot of fans
of the show thought they wouldn't see
until season 2. they're surrounded by a
group of jacksonites on patrol and
instead of checking for infection via
these CBI scanners the same ones used by
fedra they they have infection sniffing
dogs this prompts Joel to have one of
his panic attacks he remembers how even
though Ellie was immune to the infection
she still showed up positive when she
was scanned in episode 1 but much to
both his and Ellie surprised the dog
detects nothing we never get an
explanation to this in the show but if
Craig Mason and Neil druckman haven't
answered it yet in the official podcast
my best guess is since it's been more
than three months since she was last
tested the infection is completely gone
or in such low amounts that it's not
detectable it's here we meet Tommy's
wife Maria a former district attorney
for the state of Oregon it's kind of
ironic that a former criminal is now
married to a person who put criminals
away she asked for Joel's name and
invites him into the city perhaps
recognizing this could be her husband's
brother she'd undoubtedly know his name
but it remains unclear whether she's
ever seen a photo of him in the game
Maria would have seen a photo of him as
the patrol makes its way to Jackson They
alert the guards at the front gate using
this red flag perhaps it means they're
bringing hostels with them the game
gives us some more insight on what
happened between Tommy and Joel before
they split apart stating that Tommy
leaving was based on a disagreement
Tommy saw the world one way I saw the
other in fact Tommy's last words to Joel
were I don't ever want to say your
Goddamn face again a bit of a departure
from the show now there are a lot of fun
similarities between Jackson and the
show and in the game from kids playing
with snowballs a school slash daycare
and the Tipsy bison Diner I also liked
how they haven't taken down the 2003
Lights Festival sign some 20 odd years
later there's also a shop called Teton
Tunes now if you're familiar with the
game Joel has a love for singing and
playing the guitar in fact this is the
first episode he mentions that he would
have wanted to become a singer when I
was a kid I wanted to be a singer right
when I was a kid I used to want to be uh
singer of course this dream of his was
put on hold because he had Sarah at such
a young age I had Sarah when I was
pretty young I wonder if tetan Tunes
will play a larger role in season 2
seeing as how both Joel and Ellie have
this love for music after months of
searching Joel is finally reunited with
Tommy the first time we've seen the two
together since episode one and it's only
fitting that Tommy's in the middle of
building something considering that's
what Joel and Tommy did as contractors
before the pandemic Joel lanelli scarfed
down this meal at a dining hall it has
the same lights hanging from the ceiling
like those found in the church dance
scene in The Last of Us Part Two Maria
even explains on their tour that the
town has its own Interfaith church so
expect to see that in season two but by
far the coolest part of the scene is the
introduction of what could be one of The
Last of Us Part two's biggest characters
now when the credits this actress is
built simply as staring girl but for
those of you who have played the game
this is most likely Dina a character who
will become Ellie's love interest she
also Bears a striking resemblance but
for now Maria just refers to her as a
curious girl who's interested in Ellie
because she doesn't look or act like all
the other kids Maria apologizes for
their less than warm welcome to Jackson
the city keeps a low profile to avoid
Raiders and other nerduels part of this
includes keeping off the radio which is
why Joel hadn't heard from Tommy and
weeks back in the Boston QC thankfully
due to its remote location infected are
few and far between Joel asked to speak
just with family AKA Tommy where it's
then revealed that Tommy is married and
Joel is less than thrilled it's the same
reaction he gives when he finds out
Tommy is going to be a father but we'll
unpack that mess in a bit Maria settled
here in Jackson seven years ago with her
father where they'd soon become leaders
the show explains that the population of
Jackson of roughly 300 people is run by
a democratically elected Council of
which she is a member at the Stables
were introduced to a young fowl named
Shimmer in The Last of Us Part Two we
see the grown-up version of this horse
which Ellie rides to do her Patrols in
the game Ellie knows how to ride
something she learned from a man named
Winston who we meet in The Last of Us
comic Joel says he and Ellie have been
doing just fine and Ellie's face says
what the hell are you talking about
they've lost basically all of their
travel Companions and barely made it to
Jackson alive Joel and Tommy grab a
drink at the Tipsy bison well Maria
helps Ellie settle in Joel remarks that
Tommy has an age the only thing to
really change about him is his longer
hair and mustache doesn't seem like you
age much
you on the other hand you're [__] old
hilarious the two share a drink where
it's implied Tommy makes his own booze
saying all they need now is to have some
bacon and it's not long before we
realize Joel isn't being upfront to
Tommy about why he's here he lies about
Tess being fine and that Ellie is the
daughter of some bigwig Firefly that
he's been paid to transport her across
the country now Tommy tells Joel that
this Firefly Base is located a week's
ride South at the University of Eastern
Colorado the same place it's located in
the game but things are really messed up
between here and there infected Raiders
it's not an easy trip Joel wants Tommy
to come with him but Tommy says no and
Joel thinks it's because Tommy resents
him for the things they did to survive
we murdered people
and I don't judge you for it
we survived the only way we know how the
real reason he won't come he's about to
be a father in the game Tommy doesn't
have a child so this might come as a
shock to those who played what should be
joyous news is met with a stone-faced
Joel his brother he's traveled across
the country for has abandoned him to
start his own family yet another
reminder of the family Joel lost Tommy
drives home this fact delivering one of
the most gut punching lines of the
Season just because life stopped for you
doesn't mean it has to stop for me the
game's version of this ends a bit more
physical you lay your hands on me again
it won't end well for you and if it
couldn't get any worse Joel stumbles out
of the bar seeing a girl resembling his
daughter notably absent from the episode
is Tommy's gift to Jewel we learned
Tommy ventured back to their home in
Austin and picked up this photo one
which Joel does not accept meanwhile
Ellie enjoys a hot shower in a room that
looks like it hasn't been touched since
2003 the calendar is still on September
as well as the Libra horoscope from
September October of that year this room
is actually a recreation of a ranch
house found in The Last of Us Part One
they've even added a giraffe plushie and
poster on the wall giraffes are Easter
eggs found throughout the game and can
be found in episode 2 the hint at a
particularly memorable scene Maria
leaves a note that she'll be across the
street leaving Ellie this multi-colored
jacket the same one from the game not
only that she gets a diva cup but I'm
thinking between this and the Tampax
Pearl this is not what I had in mind
when they said the show would be a
period piece
across the street at Tommy and Maria's
Ellie takes note of a makeshift Memorial
above the fireplace dedicated to Joel's
daughter Sarah and Maria's son Kevin
Kevin was only three years old when he
passed just two days after Sarah's death
Ellie mistakenly assumes that both Kevin
and Sarah were Maria's up until this
point she hasn't even known Joel had a
daughter in the game it was Maria who
told Ellie about Sarah too not her you
know what
Maria told me about Sarah Ellie
Maria has a word of warning for Ellie
she knows what happens to people who
follow Joel referencing the time of
Tommy's life where he killed innocent
people to survive be careful who you put
your faith in
the only people who can betray us are
the ones we trust Maria's words
foreshadow Joel's eventual betrayal of
Ellie dumping her with Tommy but they
can also foreshadow an even bigger
betrayal that happens at the end of the
game something I'll save as a spoiler
near the end of the video but I'll give
you a heads up before we get into that
as Ellie keeps watch on Tommy and Maria
the 1977 romantic comedy the goodbye
girl plays
don't you ever do that again your lips
may say no no but this yes yes in your
eyes what the [__] an interesting title
considering Joel will soon be saying
goodbye to Ellie in fact in the next
scene Joel divulges his plan to leave
her have Tommy take her to the fireflies
instead of himself fun fact Tommy
mentions the kids in Jackson are
watching a movie in the game
kids be watching movies tonight Joel
lays everything out on the table what
happened to Tess Ellie's immunity and
his apprehension continuing on with her
he's seen how his age nearly got Ellie
killed in episode 4. because I was too
slow and too [__] deaf to hear him
coming he carries around this guilt and
now he has this added worry of his panic
attacks I couldn't
move
oh so great what if this happens when
Ellie needs him most this is why Joel
wants Tommy to take her he's younger
faster and more reliable in Joel's mind
this is what's best for Ellie yet he
doesn't take into account what she wants
so if Tommy really wants to make up for
all that evil [__] he did with Joel in
the past that evil stuff that made him
take off from him this is his chance to
make things right to make sure his child
is brought into a new world where the
virus can be eliminated forever Tommy
reluctantly agrees he'll leave at dawn
with a girl and not tell Maria in The
Game's version Maria knows but instead
of Ellie patiently waiting for him she
rides off on her own leading Tommy and
Joel to join forces to get her back Joel
finds Ellie reading the diary of the
teenage girl who once lived in this room
is this really all they had to worry
about
boys movies is this really all they had
to worry about
boys movies notice this purple flower
here similar to the purple plants that
line the road leading to Jackson in the
game unbeknownst to Joel Ellie was
listening in on his conversation with
Tommy we get this brief shot of her
walking along the empty streets of
Jackson having left the movie but we
actually never see her eavesdropping
Joel is abandoning her just like
everyone else in her life and the
dialogue here is almost word for word
from the game everybody I have cared for
has either died or left me everyone I
have cared for has either died or left
me and armed with the knowledge that he
had a daughter says
I'm not her you know Joel is well aware
you're not my daughter
I'm not sure as hell ain't your dad it's
a brutal scene but this is what needs to
be done because Joel believes this is
the best thing for her the problem is
Joel hasn't taken into account what
Ellie wants he gives her no say in the
matter so don't tell me that I'd be safe
with somebody else because the truth is
I would just be more scared so don't
tell me that I would be safer with
someone else because the truth is I
would just be more scared come Dawn
Ellie and Joel will go their separate
ways Maria warned Ellie that the only
people who can betray us are the ones we
trust Joel is obviously heartbroken over
this decision he dreams of putting up
Christmas ornaments with his daughter
his broken watch fully intact the
parallels between Ellie and his daughter
weigh heavily on him and the next
morning we find out he's had a change of
heart as Tommy arrives to pick up Ellie
and take her to the Stables Joel is
already there preparing to steal a horse
I would have gave you one
I don't know he tells Ellie she deserves
to have a choice you deserve a choice I
still think you'd be better off with
Thomas let's go this is an interesting
choice of words for Jules we'll find at
the end of the season he'll make a
life-changing decision for Ellie without
giving her a choice but more on that
near the end Tommy tells Joel to make
for the I-25 a stretch of highway that
extends from Wyoming all the way to New
Mexico from there they can reach the
university and hopefully this Firefly
base they've been desperately searching
for the two say goodbye with Tommy
promising a place for both of them when
they come back
Joel's decision to stay with Ellie marks
a shift in his behavior the guy who
wouldn't teach her how to hunt is now
teaching her how to use a rifle and is
enjoying it too Ellie's never known A
World Before the pandemic and asked Joel
if everything ran like Jackson back then
his response is oblique commentary on
society today stating that the world was
divided by people who wanted to own
everything and those who wanted nothing
at all and which group did Joel belong
to neither I just did my job and just
like in the game Joel spends his time
going over the intricacies of football
with Ellie a game she'd probably never
have seen in real life but if you make
it to 10 yards then you're back to first
now yep and if you cleared the 10 yards
then you're back in first now first down
that's right it takes them five days to
reach the I-25 and lucky for them the
Trek has been relatively easy they
reached the university whose mascot is
ironically a type of sheep in both the
game and show Ellie Muses about
University life people would live here
and like what go to classes and stuff
would live here and just stepped even
though they were all grown up University
being a place to find yourself leads
Joel to reveal his real dream instead of
the sheep farm he'd rather be a singer
this is the first time in the show he
talks about his love for singing and the
guitar but because he had Sarah at such
a young age a music career was never
really in the books for him if Ellie is
saving the world the least Joel can do
is one day sing for her will you sing it
for me later
I'm Gonna Save the [__] world man
it's the least you can do for me like in
the game we get these roaming bands of
monkeys which Joel surmises were once
part of the old medical labs in the game
there's even a tape recorder of a doctor
being bit by one of these monkeys some
of which were infected
[Applause]
you did me the mystery behind the
fireflies abrupt departure from the
university is fleshed out more in the
game via series of documents and
recordings x-ray images show that
research was done and those infected by
cordyceps so whatever was going on here
likely had something to do with finding
a cure and or understanding how the
infection works this is why Marlene
desperately wanted Ellie to make her way
here from the game we find out the
University was getting slammed by
infected in fact there's a whole section
where Joel has to take down a bloater by
himself using a flamethrower long story
short the university became a less than
ideal location to continue their work
and the decision was made to move to
Saint Mary's and Salt Lake City in the
show we see this giant cork board with a
bunch of push pins all leading towards
Salt Lake City while in the game we hear
a voice recording from a doctor now
decomposed skeleton mentioning this
location
they've all returned to St Mary's
Hospital in Salt Lake City one part
that's absent from the game is Joel's
Trek through the university dorms which
tells a grim story of the dorm students
holding themselves up during the start
of the pandemic finding out no one is
coming for them and eventually
succumbing to the infected the Firefly
sign indicates they're in the right
place but everyone seems to have left a
packing list confirms their suspicion
the fireflies aren't here like in the
game Joel and Ellie hear a commotion
upstairs only to be startled when they
find out it's just the monkeys as we
take a closer look at the cork board we
see these multiple pins indicating what
seem to be Firefly encampments all
leading towards Salt Lake there's even a
bunch of Red Pins originating from
Seattle and major location in The Last
of Us Part Two we also see a bunch of
radio stations which the fireflies may
have been using to communicate with one
another their investigation is cut short
when a group of Raiders descend upon
them in the game Joel is pushed from the
second floor and onto this Steel Rod
while the show has him attacked by a
Raider and a part of a baseball bat
lodged in his stomach even depicting
Joel grabbed this dude didn't snap his
neck like one of many of the kill
animations in the game the game is much
more brutal in this section as Ellie and
an extremely wounded Joel make their
escape but I understand why the show has
a more toned down version it's just not
believable to have someone wounded in
the gut taking down 20 plus guys both
versions end with Joel and Ellie
escaping on Horseback with Joel
collapsing I don't know where the [__]
I'm going what the [__] I'm gonna do
tell me what to do
[Music]
and the show ends with a rendition of
depech modes never let me down the same
80s song that played at the end of
episode 1. if we remember from Bill and
Joel's smuggling code 80s means trouble
now I want to briefly get into that big
spoiler I talked about earlier so if you
want to avoid that turn away now when
Maria said the ones we trust are the
ones who betray us it foreshadows Joel's
decision to lie to Ellie about the
events that happen at the end of the
game he fails to mention the fireflies
were going to kill her in order to
synthesize a vaccine and how he saved
her from this death he also lies to her
saying there are others who are immune
dozens in fact but the fireflies have
been unable to create a cure in fact
they've given up altogether he also
fails to mention he killed Marlene to
make matters worse Ellie has Joel swear
to him that everything he told her about
the fireflies is true and he doubles
down
I swear it's a betrayal by someone Ellie
trusts the most and sets up the events
for The Last of Us Part Two but we still
have a long ways to go before we get
there that's it for now what did you
think of episode five I want to hear
your thoughts and theories in the
comments below thanks for watching be
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember this is the cloud Moon
we're Communists
I didn't like that